i think the the the real future will be
you know
home care and hospitals at home so you
won't
have to go even to see a doctor or to go
to a hospital to get to get care
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
this one is all about digital healthcare
meet nom gabisson
vertical manager of digital health at
facebook
nom gabisson is the vertical manager for
digital health at facebook
an ex microsoft venture capital fund
singularity team and startups executive
he is passionate about marketing growth
business development and purpose-driven
companies nam gabisson thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders
how are you all the way from tel aviv
i'm good i'm good thank you meghan
michael good to see you good to see you
it's great to see you you know i have a
feeling that we're just a few blocks
away from each other and unfortunately
we can do this in person
but that is exactly what we're going to
talk about you know the different world
that we're living in the different
transformations
that you know it has been have been
happening the past decade accelerated by
covet
because you are the vertical lead for
digital health at facebook
and what i think is going to be a
spectacular is talking about first year
journey
all the way from microsoft to amazing
startups like mobley
to being in a vc fund and singularity
team
now to to doing the amazing work you're
doing with startups and businesses at
facebook
so i'm gonna stop talking now and it is
your turn tell me a little bit about
yourself
and and tell me a little bit about the
journey that you're on
wow okay that's that's uh that's quite a
journey you know what i'm gonna start
from high school i think that's
something
a bit bizarre about myself so usually we
go to kindergarten but we can start from
high school if you want
i was born in athletes i don't know if
the kid over there is is so known but
um i studied out in a in a school in a
high school called talamayalin
so it's it's a very famous out out kind
of high school i study theater over
there
afterwards i went to the military and
was in a combat unit
um and and from that actually about more
than 10 years ago i started my first
role actually in microsoft
after was in worked in a tiny startup
and really got passionate into it
um over there at microsoft i was mainly
dealing with like advanced marketing
tactics
online sales was kind of something that
it was really unique
so i had the privilege of working with
like really the best brands like xbox
and microsoft
um office windows um
and even some that today sounds really
familiar like azure which is cloud
computing for microsoft but back then
it was prior even to the to the era of
satya nadal
it was a deck more than a decade ago
yeah i'm that old
so so that was microsoft um and back
then
working with azure so i started to learn
really about the tech scene in israel
and met a lot of startups
um and worked with them through
microsoft ventures and microsoft
accelerators
and then i decided to to shift and went
into vc the
vcf singular team er chairman was
michelle
and also worked in some of his startups
so i'm not going to talk about that a
lot today although i'm
i'm sure that a lot of the listeners are
quite curious
but i can say that it was a roller
coaster
literally a roller coaster doing amazing
stuff and then also
do failing a lot so failure is is quite
of a
big chunk of what i've done in in my
career
and from that i moved to micros to
facebook which
again i think facebook is such a unique
company you know there is this trend
talking about responsibility in tech
and i think there isn't a company
similar to facebook that truly
understand
um what is like how to be responsible
for what we're doing and trying to do
better
in the world trying to connect people
from all around the world
and then really zoom in maybe on what
facebook israel is doing so i think
the the office in israel is is basically
compiled out of two activities one is
the r d
one of the biggest r on the outside of
menlo park sits over here in tel aviv
and serrano office
and over there we have some of the most
i would say
cool and ambitious projects of facebook
so we've got novi
and we've got the entire express wi-fi
and fb lite
and even a team of for ar and vr for
facebook so that's like
the r d on facebook in israel and then
we also have the business sector sitting
in rochester
which i'm literally like living two
minutes from the office
the the far far far close but far office
and over there basically what we're
doing is we're supporting
the entire um israeli ecosystem so we're
like the api for everything facebook
but the main attention and and i think
what we're really famous about within
the company
is working with hyper growth companies
so
um startups from different fields from
the classic e-commerce
to fintech where we have trading and in
shorter companies
so lemonade for example and other really
famous ipos this year
um also working with b2b so yeah there
is a b2b
on facebook and we're doing marketing
for b2b specifically
b to s and b and sas companies we've got
entertainment and media
um consumer tech which is a lot of
utility apps um
we have marketplaces in agro-big gators
with companies like fiverr for example
and then we have digital health which
i'm going to talk about in a minute
um but i think what we give to our
clients is
like top-notch consulting in three main
pillars i would say
so obviously marketing everything
related to marketing so
from the tonal voice to the messaging to
the tracking and attribution
and afterwards how you scale it and
getting to consumers all around the
world and really doing it in in a quite
an effective way
so that's number one number two is
everything related to business and and
strategy
trying to literally leverage the
powerhouse of data which is facebook
both data and consumers and on companies
to help our
you know business associate to make
smarter decisions
and the last one is everything related
to product and tech which is at the core
of like the tech scene in israel so
trying to help our partners with their
product
and trying to integrate really advanced
and smart integration to facebook
technologies
um so i think that's what we're doing on
top of that we're also engaging with
ngos
in israel with communities with vcs by
the way
which is something really unique because
we understand that our partners are
startups
and therefore we also need to be engaged
with two seats in their board which is
the investors in the field so we also
build like this very
special value exchange with vcs so i
think that's what we're doing in
facebook
now yeah yeah tell me how much you
wanted me to go deep into digital health
at facebook or digital health in israel
well i think what you said before is
it's a perfect segue to what we're going
to talk about because you mentioned the
word responsibility and you mentioned
the word that
you can you can't really think of many
other companies like facebook that are
think
they're taking as much responsibility
and thinking responsibly about
about the things that they have to do
and i think that what what you're
talking about here really is you know
this idea that you
are shifting consumer behaviors you know
all the time
this is literally you know working in a
company that is moving the needle
whether it be an
ar and vr or whether that may be and you
know in digital health and
by understanding that you're taking this
responsibility to shift consumer
behavior
and think critically about what that
means and what is what and
how how do you actually act upon that in
a responsible manner i think that is the
most exciting thing
that i'm waiting to hear from because of
what i'm excited to really understand
here
is from the digital health perspective
what is the what does digital health
look like in the last decade or so
what's been happening with covet what is
your part in it and what what can we get
excited about
you know this integration and you know i
know that this is a topic that usually
talk about you for just two or three
minutes so you know we have 10 minutes
left
so we can talk about everything right
yeah
okay so talking about covid by the way
is quite of a of a
difficult task you know with all the
different variations and stuff like that
maybe there will be a variation out of
this
conversation but um i want to talk
for a second about like you mentioned
the shift in consumer trend so i'm
not thinking that facebook is literally
making that shift i think that facebook
is a platform
that is giving people the power to make
specific changes or to build in our
specific example to build communities
and really trying to bring the world
closer together and
and i think with that comes that
responsibility i was talking about
to play a key role in creating a much
more safer
and inclusive and an engaged kind of
healthier community
and from that we're obviously trying to
improve healthier
health outcomes for people around the
world um but talking for a second maybe
about
facebook like health on facebook so
i think that facebook have you know kind
of a very
unique opportunity to play a role with
that health landscape
um i know that we're not fully invested
within it like for example microsoft or
apple or google
and we're still basically collaborating
today with ngos
with health organization and with
research researchers
but i think that we're doing it from a
really unique place that is playing on
our strength on facebook strength i
think that we're doing it
on through communities we're doing it
through connectivity
so connecting people to information and
driving action which is
informed by by better information and
then in the end i think that we're doing
it through
a quite of an amazing product i just
published about it in my linkedin
i think it was yesterday like the annual
review of data for good
so data for good is is a project where
facebook basically gives
some of our data in obviously super
private and hashed way
to research and health organization to
try
and combat the kovi in 2020 and trying
to find
disease map prevention in different
areas and i think over there you can
really find how
we can enable people and help them
improve
you know health outcomes and friends and
family
uh well-being around the world so i
think that's really
on a nutshell um what facebook is doing
in the area
of health and now i would even go and
say
maybe something about an area which is
really passion for me which is
health in the israeli texting so i think
um like we build the taxing around
really deep tech and i think that today
we understand
and we're stealing with pride from some
of the improvements
and the disruption that we brought to
other verticals into the healthcare
area so we know that the healthcare
system in the us
which is the the main target audience
for for israeli startups
is fragmented it's not effective and
it's very much
expensive
yeah and you're someone that lives over
there with i would probably even
i'm going to put words in your mouth and
saying that it's not optimizing for
better care
or for people patient engagement and the
reason why i'm saying
people are not patient is i think that
today
digital health pure digital health
companies so companies that were born in
this era
of the last five to ten years and
specifically companies that was born in
kovit
that are not thinking only about the
payers or the providers
but they're thinking about the patient
and they're thinking about the patient
in a much more holistic way
they're trying to capture the human
being around the symptom
or around the reimbursement code and
they're trying to literally build a
product
that will a provide better care b
will connect all the dots of incentives
and payments and financial aspects
of of healthcare in the us and c
will try to understand that
healthier living today is not a matter
of being ill or being
healthy like literally no one is healthy
anymore
like i think we all went through a year
where we realized
that you can have a virus
quite a nasty virus inside of you and
you don't know about it
so i think that's one of the big shifts
that was happening and i think that a
lot of
israeli companies are taking some of the
learnings from gaming industry
from insurtech from fintech companies
from e-commerce were talking about like
better delivery of care and literally
bringing it into the healthcare
um as a sector amazing so
now looking at this as an ecosystem and
you're obviously you know sitting in a
row where you get to see the integration
and cooperation and collaboration of
between a lot of between a lot of these
organizations and what i'm curious about
as a bystander is i'm saying okay i'm
seeing a bunch of these
each company is tackling a different
part of of the puzzle right so if we're
looking at digital health as a puzzle
then every company is doing this uh
there's different pieces one thing that
i keep thinking about is saying
you know what with the problem that
we're starting out with is that it's so
fragmented and there's so little
collaboration cooperation
then what does the future hold so now
that we have you know disruptors coming
in and changing the system
what can and should be done to make sure
that things work together
much more tightly and neatly and so that
there is a win-win situation and it's
not like a winner tickle or zero-sum
game again
okay hmm i'm gonna think for just like
another two seconds
okay so i love that i think
i think trying to to map for a second
the opportunities
so what we do know is we have
some kind of industry consolidation
right now so we're seeing like
yes really mega mega deals digital
health ipos
and we understand that there is a lot of
hype
capital and and trying to build like
much more of a holistic offerings in the
digital health space so it's
coming from between wellness into health
tech which is a much more regulated
place so i think that's one trend i
think the second trend is
we saw like the hype of remote care and
telemedicine
but we realized today in you know in a
place
in a time in place and time where we can
visualize postcode world in israel maybe
it's it's even shorter than what
our colleagues in the u.s can can
visualize but we understand that
telemedicine was only the beginning
and in a way right it's not yeah it's
not the full disruption like the full
disruption will be when we're gonna have
like full care flow and processes that
are
fully digital and real-time data playing
a big role in how to monitor
ensure better care ensure the engagement
that we talked about and i think
the the the real future will be you know
home care and hospitals at home so you
won't have to go
even to see a doctor or to go to a
hospital to get to get care so i think
that's like another
area the the major one in terms of like
you know
any disruption is coming usually from
availability of information
so we see a lot of data pouring into a
specific area
and from a second from different
perspective seeing
affordable services so you need in order
to disruption to really erupt you need
to have like
the financial aspect getting taken care
of and right now
we're seeing a lot of innovation in in
how to to manage that from price
transparency to better delivery of care
so i think that's an area um and last
but not least
i think that in a post-covered world
what we're going to see is a shift in in
the
data and privacy sentiment and i think
that we're seeing today
much more um business model innovation
so direct to consumer or delivery
alternatives
we're seeing different payments methods
and models
we we're seeing even you know national
retailers like walmart
that are getting into the health space
so we're literally saying
a place where everyone is trying like to
get a hold
on this patient journey which is
today really complicated and doesn't
start when you have
some kind of a disease it starts from
the day you you're born
so that that was quite a big
announcement in the end but
i'm sure you get it right but no
one thing that i that i'm always curious
about and i love talking about people's
journeys and i and
you know i love the fact that we're
starting out all the way from your high
school days
and towards the different things that
you've gone through all the way to now
being you know a game changer in the
israeli ecosystem as a part of facebook
and one thing that i you know i'm deeply
curious about is your
focus your deep and dedicated focus
moving from you know
a world of marketing to a world of
venture capital working
previously with a bunch of startups with
er with mobley
and then you decide okay i'm gonna go
into health tech what was it
why health tech what happened you know
in in 2016 when you're saying
this is my focus because that is a
pretty dramatic shift in in your own
journey
okay you're getting into sensitive parts
over here but uh it's okay
um i i was injury i got an injury in the
in my army
um i have like some kind of um
medical background that's why i also got
my second vaccine
about a few days ago um and i think that
i was doing this business and
entrepreneurship journey with myself
and learning a lot really so for example
microsoft is is like a business
business school for business um in the
real world and and then
the vc and the startups taught me a lot
about you know how to fail right
and how to learn from from failures and
i think when i got to facebook i learned
that
like you can have a purpose and you can
do the work that you love
and still drive enormous amount of
impact
while doing so and i think that today
what i'm trying to do
working with vcs and working with
startups is to really build this
strategic relationship coming out of you
know mutual
interest which which are impactful
interest
and and with the 12 settles of the
israeli ecosystem and trying to create
more
d2c startups in that field in the
digital health field
that facebook i hope play a small
hopefully maybe big as we as we move
along part in in their success
and and that will literally drive a
change in the world for for people so
i think that is my like humble
contribution
i would say to to remember like
noam as a soldier and and the stuff that
i was dealing back then
wow i love that no what is the one thing
you're most excited about
you know looking forward into the
digital health tech space obviously
it's a big unknown and there's a lot of
exciting paths where it could go
and but what is really most exciting for
you when you think about you know
the world that your kids and my kids are
going to grow up in
so i think it's going to be the
immediate and customization
of health care throughout
the stages of life so i think today
we're still
have some kind of deviation between the
different stages in life and how we
look at our well-being or health or even
how we look at
death in some point and i think that the
future
with the right technology and also with
the right obviously
again responsibility ownership over data
and consumerization of all that stuff so
i think our
my kids have a fresh nine nine old uh
months baby born
gone um i think he will have just better
care not just physically you know just
also like emotion right
emotionally and and and
you name it you know holistically i
would say a hundred percent
i i think that that's exactly right i
think that you know we're gonna see some
incredible things
when it comes to prosthetics and you
know and obviously cancer research and
als and a lot of those
things that you know today are just
impossible or seem impossible
we're going to see them resolve but i
think that what we're going to be really
seeing is this tale
of you know the just the average
experience the average healthcare
experience whether it's mental health
physical health
emotional well-being that is going to
have such a higher standard because
today you know a lot of the times we
take it for granted
where we are that we have access to a
doctor we can go and get the vaccine or
we can go you know to visit our
clinician one well
there's billions of people that don't
even have that and i'm thinking about
my friends and counterparts in africa
and india and china that just don't have
that access
and i'm so incredibly excited for the
accessibility and availability to be
disseminated
and and knowing that you know my
children and your children and everybody
and the next generation you know
equality the
the gap will be reduced a little bit so
i completely agree with what you're
saying
uh and i love that norm thank you so so
much
for spending your time with me uh yeah
the last question that i have is the
most
it's the most important question three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
okay patient
honest
and probably um creativity
i love that stay safe and stay home
thank you
i look forward to grabbing that i'm
looking forward to grabbing that beer in
person
i'm not drinking beer in the last six
months so it's probably either a good
whiskey
or something that's but yeah for sure
i'll go for the first one